[Applause]
[Music]
the seasons are changing but you know
what never changes there are new video
games all the time so let's talk about
some of the coolest ones launching this
week these would probably pair nicely
with some Szechuan sauce because first
up is Rick and Morty virtual reality
making its way onto PlayStation VR this
game comes from the team behind job
simulator so you can expect that same
level of goofiness but with all the
gizmos and gadgets from the hit Adult
Swim show you can step in other
dimensions solve puzzles push weird
buttons and experience the world of Rick
and Morty in the silliest ways possible
that comes to psvr on Tuesday April 10th
here's hoping we get to experience some
interdimensional cable next what do you
do it's two brothers and two brothers
speaking of multiple dimensions let's
talk about super Darrel deluxe Darrell
is the new kid at waterfalls high school
but he's about to get an education and
stuff that's way crazier than math and
ho mech this Metroidvania sends you
through all sorts of crazy environments
to face down Grim Reaper's sharks robot
snakes and more you can level up to
unlock skills and equip cool gear and
find plenty of Secrets along the way
super Darrel deluxe comes to ps4 Xbox
one PC and switch on Tuesday the 10th
you know what else has monsters to fight
extinction and the monsters here are
absolutely massive oh Gers you play as
evil and you have to use a variety of
acrobatics and combat skills to take
down the big beasts threatening your
world you can even make your own
scenarios and skirmish mode and
challenge others for the high score the
ogres march on to ps4 Xbox one and PC on
the 10th the world is also threatened in
dark Rose Valkyrie but this time it's
from a meteor that's spreading disease
across 1920s Japan what that means for
you is
RPG with Phoenix right like segments
where you'll have to interview the party
and identify any traitors 3% of the
world is already dead and it's up to you
to save the rest dark Rose Valkyrie
comes to PC via Steam on the 10th now
let's talk about a much more positive
game Robocraft infinity is all about
designing a robot that fights flies
drives or does whatever else you can
think of then taking it into battle with
other bots online you can share your
design with others and try out their
Robo creations to Robocraft infinity
comes to Xbox one and PC on Wednesday
the 11th when it'll also launch day and
date on Xbox game paths if you're
curious about what else is offered on
that service you can check out any of
our game pass write-ups over at GameSpot
and those are some of the hottest games
we'll be playing this week as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for watching guys and I'll
be back with another batch of new games
next Sunday